hallo easy german fans lieben und miri
und kari fragen heute zwei fragen und
zwar erstens was ist euer lieblingsfilm
und zweitens wenn ihr in einem film
einen charakter nach spielen könntest
wer wäre das
das könnt ihr übrigens auch gerne in
unseren kommentaren beantworten und wir
suchen und finden jetzt unsere antworten
in der city und im schillergymnasium
kompanie losgeht
dann frage ich gleich mal los was ist
denn ihr lieblingsfilm
ach du lieber gott oder zwei oder drei
casablanca und gibt es da auch eine ganz
bestimmte szene die sie gerne mögen ja
wenn sie die für die zuschauer die das
nicht kennen kurz beschrieben so gut
sehen
das ist die szene wo er am klavier
spielt adams äpfel
worum geht es in dem film adams äpfel
den film adams äpfel geht es um hier zum
gut und böse eigentlich es geht um einen
fahrer der quasi blind für alles ist was
böse ist ist aber umgeben in seiner in
seiner verein vom menschen die
eigentlich nur böses tun
er bildet sich ein dass sie halt alle
dass ich alle bekehrt für ihn
funktioniert das auch alles aber da tut
sich überhaupt gar nichts so und darum
geht's eigentlich noch wendung hier und
da habe ich glaube es geht jetzt so weit
was ist dein lieblings film mein
lieblingsfilm inception
wissen sie noch wie der hauptdarsteller
heißt aus lich humphrey bogart und
könnten sie sich auch vorstellen den
mann zu spielen
nein der ist zu gut gewesen
welche rolle werden sie dann in einem
film gerne mal übernehmen irgendwann die
ganz kleine bilder zum beispiel als egal
vielleicht als gemüsehändler eine kleine
nebenrolle als gemüsehändler geht raus
wir werden und zwar um herrn für sie
danke dass ihr bett und eine
lieblingsszene hast du dir auch spontan
nein würdest du auch mal gerne mit
inception mitspielen
ja und welche rolle wird es daran
übernehmen wollen
leonardo dicaprio was macht er in dem
film für die zuschauer die den film
nicht kennen auch so schauspieler und
was für eine rolle übernimmt er die
hauptrolle sehr gut und knapp
beantwortet die fragen gott mein
lieblingsfilm pulp fiction glaube ich
gibt es da eine bestimmte szene die so
ganz besonders mag
ich glaube der klassiker für sie im auto
sitzen und über cheeseburger diskutieren
die ist halt direkt am anfang die hat
mich damals ziemlich gequetscht hallo
paris vater ich habe eine frage an dich
was ist dein lieblings film mein
lieblingsfilm james bond james bond
filme und welcher von den
unterschiedlichen james bond
schauspieler an gefällt dir am besten
george s m b war demnach vor pierce
brosnan wird nur einmal das gemacht weil
ich den film gut fand und würdest du
könntest du dir auch fast einmal ein
james bond zu spielen
wer jetzt nicht mehr früher ja auf jeden
fall mein lieblingsfilm eigentlich
hinter dem horizont
worum geht es in dem vertrag mit robbie
williams
robin williams der schon gestorben ist
ein sehr trauriger film der beschreibt
wie das leben nach dem tod
ausschauen könnte und er befreit dann
seine frau von der hölle
was ist denn dein lieblings film mein
lieblingsfilm das ist starker von andrej
tarkowski verwirrung jetzt in dem film
was geht um einen samen jäger denn ein
sperrgebiet immer wieder eindringt um so
im grunde sich selbst zu finden also
schon sehr speziell russisch wäre da
nicht mal was dahin diensten und deinen
lieblings willst du das geraten
rate mal du bist spielt in godzilla
große last
ich mag tatsächlich sehr sehr gerne sehr
gerne den film sin city
ja weil er auf einer comic buch reihe
basiert von frank miller und der film
ist grafisch so geil umgesetzt kari der
film ist grafisch so kalt umgesetzt fast
so wie das original die bücher ok und
bei adams äpfel gibt es da vielleicht
ein charakter den sie gern spielen
würdest den fahrer weil ich es ist schon
ist schon segen nicht mehr zu kriegen
wie schlimm alles um einen rum ist so
verdrängt das halt einfach das früher so
das kannst du dich an den schauspieler
erinnern
der ist richtig cool der macht auch
andere gute filme eigentlich nur gute
filme also es gibt eigentlich keine
schlechten filme mit ihm
du würdest gerne einmal eine rolle von
christoph waltz übernehmen auch unter
und würdest du sagen dass einer seiner
lieblingsschauspieler ist hast deine
lieblings schauspielerin bist du
schauspielerin ja auch unter anderem
dann bist du mein lieblingsschauspieler
gut dann sind wir hier fertig kennst du
die szene mit barbara streisand wo sie
unter der dusche steht bei die nackte
kanone
welches lied sie das signal memories
oder so ähnlich einmal googeln bitte
einmal googeln bitte danke maria
danke auch okay welchen bösewicht wird
es zu einem james bond film spielen oder
vielleicht in einem ganz bestimmten
james bond weiße hinweise was macht der
beißer für die zuschauer die den nicht
kennen er hat so metalszene und fast
alles kaputt kann drahtseile durchbeißen
kann aber auch menschen auf essen und
sogar alles klar ich gehe ja nicht so
einfach aber ich glaube ich würde den
kinderfilm aussuchen vielleicht so harry
potter mal einmal durch hogwarts laufen
und wirklich ja dabei sein in der
zauberwelt oder so irgendwas muss viele
effekte gibt wo irgendwelche sachen
durch die luft fliegen
vielleicht als bibi blocksberg auf dem
besen durch die gegend fliegen oder so
welchem haus gehörst du an welchem haus
ich angehöre
das weiß ich gar nicht so genau also ich
hoffe ich bin im herzen wissen aber
manchmal kommt das böse syrien macht
euch meist nicht so gelaufen und wer wie
was spielst du denn dann in dem film
figur der film wurde mit echten leuten
gedreht und in dem film gibt es ein paar
geile rollen ehrlich gesagt würde ich
gerne eine rolle spielen von einer der
prostituierten in old town
da gibt es eine die kann voll krass
fesseln und die ist einfach krass drauf
und dann gibt's noch statt mit jessica
alba die später auch mit bruce willis
spielt auch mit und clive owen spielt
auch mit brittany murphy also sehr sehr
viele bekannte schauspieler die ja die
alle zusammen so eine kleine stadt
beleben bewohnern werden bruce willis in
stirb langsam
welche szene gefällt dir am besten in
stirb langsam alle und welche oder
langsam stirbt
das war eine schöne episode mit dir
endlich bist du wieder da gewesen
danke dass ihr zu mir gekommen seid sehr
nett von euch und die übrigens mir hat
die antwort mit dem gemüsehändler am
besten gefallen
der portier wollte eine kleine
nebenrolle als gemüsehändler haben und
war auch gemüsehändler wer war das
der gemüsehändler hier um die ecke achim
@ ja wir jetzt fragen wir uns natürlich
was ist eure lieblings rolle in einem
film und das könnt ihr jetzt mal ihr
könnt jetzt mal euer vokabular aus der
heutigen episode testen und das hier
unten in die kommentare schreiben auf
deutsch
welche rolle würdet ihr spielen wenn ihr
einem film mitspielen könnte und zwar in
welchem film schreibt es uns in die
kommentare und wenn ihr lust habt uns
unterstützen
dann freuen wir uns mitglied bei easy
därmen zu werden bei patchen das könnte
hier und machen wir gar nicht hier und
hier unten und hier könnt ihr uns
abonnieren damit ihr mehr easy german
seed ja abonniert und st mary dass dort
immer wieder ein tolles 1